[MUSIC PLAYING]
GLORYROSE DY: What we do is we
teach different communities.
Especially those
who are off grid,
those who don't have
access to technology,
even computers and
smartphones, we
teach them how to
make digital stories.
So digital stories
are videos, actually,
in the form of storytelling.
GLORYPEARL DY: When
we were acknowledged
for a social good by
Smart Pay it Forward,
it was there that we
learned that other-- there
was an opportunity
to be sustainable.
We can't just do
this as volunteers.
We need to have resources.
We were also recognized by
British Council Ideation Camp.
And there we learned
about how to turn this--
GLORYROSE DY: Social good.
GLORYPEARL DY:
--company-- social good
into a social enterprise.
So there we built,
really, a business model
helping, doing
the digital story,
and people-centered
design, and trying
to look for opportunities
for financial sustainability.